I don't know if I'm supposed to be able
to hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to unforgiving on northern
him now I played this game as a demo a
while back and it scared the pants off
of me there was a giant troll in the
woods and it was horrifying but now the
full game is released now I don't know
if the opening to this game is gonna be
the same as the original demo it might
be and if it is the same that I'm
actually gonna play through it
oh oh oh that's not good oh hey this is
uh this is not the same okay yeah
well you're over there for your Viet
champagne mood later man the abrini
factus Tintin bageno say on that yeah
going in Ordnung men not mysterious
attire Sowmya so nothing mysterious ohta
beautiful jet Abbas Amazon fire can
you're almost a turtle Gator incident
the corner whoa [ __ ] dick bag okay all
right well I don't know what's happening
but I'm glad I kicked that guy in the
back of the head oh no oh no where am I
hello oh god damn it
[Music]
you want another kick look you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me
nobody you vote for back that's too
young
okay no identifiers on the wisdom of
every school elite opening the door
Dora's problem here's your horrid
problem Dave emit problem
the hard emit problem for a first day of
school
makes me thing you start swimming idiota
brochure Timmy
probably alibi your parameter Oh Dean
Cheryl turtle draw with help at the Luca
[Music]
what about yeah nah it's not bad I
become a honey everyone that's the best
what is what what it that's that's my
brother what is what what did what did
he expect would happen you try to get I
thought I thought then I you were just
some a horrible person and you were
kidnapping me
and you're still orrible person for
kidnapping me do you better get even
thought I'd do it okay I don't think
your actions are justified at all
I didn't see your face I didn't
recognize you bro but this seems bad
being out here in the middle of the
woods with her
[Music]
okay all right where are you going buddy
so what is my quote-unquote problem that
you're trying to stage an intervention
about what would you what would you say
that if you had to stata shout it at the
top of your lungs in the middle of a
crowded forest just go ahead and whisper
it in my ear we are we stand about
you're well-read well I'll turn this off
first most of 807 a school okay wait but
if I mean if we crash the car we
couldn't be too far from a minute like a
burner phone
oh yeah no more drama rooms back from
doing Emporia like it now we're bonding
okay I guess you are my brother so Oh
bro you might want to watch out about
the strings I just heard in the distance
what do you do some stupid come on
okay all right okay yeah push the giant
tree yeah push it real good man
I'll help like yes whoo yeah ah yeah
we're so strong oh there are now I'm
helping I wasn't helping before all
right
goodness gracious you uprooted that
thing well if I go then me first I
suppose yeah it seems safe good maneuver
there bro all right bro careful bro done
and all I know that maneuver was in the
middle of the back yeah we're now gonna
we're just gonna ignore the fact that
that sounded like a scream just an until
dawn situation where everyone just
ignores everything anyway tweren't
nothing worked out it was a whole lot of
nothing
and definitely nothing good yes scratch
oh I'm always careful you shut your face
I know me and my addiction are totally
fine you don't need to get in the way of
me and whatever the hell my addiction is
drugs sex maybe I don't know water okay
sure yeah you learned something how far
we got swept away I guess that explains
my earlier question but I still don't
buy it the bunch of phony baloney I
heard
good yes there's referees in the woods
whistling oh that oh that was a rumbly
bumbly hey wait Doug dude bro what I
don't stop tap dancing for one second
and look at the doll pinned into the
tree which is probably bad bro could you
stop for a second and look at all the
[ __ ] that's happening in front of
you hate that alright bro yeah don't
mind me just screaming behind you I'm
sick of my [ __ ] I'm addicted to talking
out my ass that's what I'm addicted to
well I could see some things it looked
like horrible shadows and shapes
oh there you're I thought I lost you
someone else is not gonna tree down and
make a bridge Oh someone already did bro
roh-roh I don't like this bro bro all
right bro I trust you know but stop
mentioning the goddamn camera display
this I'll avoid out there who's got a
harp in a xylophone why there's so many
orchestra members lost in the woods
oh good at cave yeah there's gonna be my
favorite thing oh no it's not a game
it's just an overhang I'd like to think
that any time someone from any sort of
concert or choir orchestra if they get
lost into the woods just to reassure
themselves they'd start playing in a
creepy manner it's like if I'm the
scariest thing in the wood no one can
kill me
everyone gonna stay away bro someone
just screamed but bro rody not hear
those drums ah the choir we found them
bro bro
oh wow okay all right everybody bro
there's a lot of musical cues happening
bro that my gamer instincts are kicking
in about and then suddenly it's a whole
lot of nothing all right bye bro I think
this is where we never see each other
again okay all right well oh hi oh Jesus
all right well hello ah moose good
old-fashioned moose well we but we might
one ask daddle bro listen bro I don't
know just keep it between you and me but
I think I think there might be a monster
in these woods for all I know we could
have been Liu bang throw the same shag
meadow wood I saw something up there did
you see something I saw something I
knows a log never mind it was a branch
zoo the troll I don't know what's a
troll and what's a branch where is all
this shrubbery gone there's only trees
and no bushes what kind of weird-ass
woods these these I don't know what's
going on bro but you better bro all
right I keep calling crazy because I
keep going like it's a thing and then
it's nothing and I don't like it oh
there's the shrub all right bro bro
start talking about camp I'm starting to
become a little bit perturbed I liked it
better when you've droned on and on
about camp okay
stop doing that again don't do that
well no doc let's go to box Oh another
of the pushing tricks eh well what good
is that gonna do it's not gonna reach
all the way across all right whatever
you say bro let's do this together Britt
okay here we go let me wipe the Moose
blood on this tree here okay well good
that dude oh yeah me me me yeah me all
me oh well bye bro no just jump it it's
not that bad
jump oh wow that's pretty fast all right
well okay alright then see you around
yeah you guys Oh see I could jump you
could jump - alright see you bro I'm
alone now all by myself
just with the orchestra gonna go well
for me bro
I feel safe Oh bro there you are okay
all right bro hey bro look
I'm a new farm Singh in fact that have
led it was the food chat the hard
okay okay good luck alright you don't
die either because apparently there's
many ways for you to die around here
alright see you bro okay on my own know
who's gonna talk to me about camp I
didn't have to talk to myself like a
crazy person that's a troll is that a
troll troll it's a bush that's a bush
this looks like a troll you shadows so
spider the branch natural no oh why do I
need to run why are you telling me that
I need to run why would I in this
situation need to run all right I'm
gonna run then there we go
ah Marsh oh hope I get some leeches haha
there's just biting my nether regions
oh good up dog okay that's not good I
why did I just do what what what I
drowned
I just I drowned i drowned you know I
just walk slowly into the lagoon and I
drowned okay all right excuse me for
being a little incredulous about that
okay good thing they set up these
convenient bridges I don't know who did
that wigs a power line do that okay
almost drowned
what the [ __ ] ugh
hi I'm Aiman I'm gonna drown now okay
all right well okay all right
[Music]
okay I didn't know that this was a swamp
from Lord of the Rings the one with all
the ghosts in the water
alrighty then okey-dokey then
alrighty then so that's how it's gonna
be
what's with this car oh the cars being
used as generator oh ok alright then
oooh free flashlight no question mark Oh
fuses oh ok ok I got this I got this
look it's all going to the right or left
but there's nothing over there so I
gotta go to the it's all gonna go to the
right right nope ok alright that's no
good ok so I need to find some fuses new
things but what is this building is it
like some kind of a Ford or something
their way in gonna go around hello ohh
oh goody
you wouldn't happen perchance to have a
flashlight would you I think that maybe
there's a lot of death in this building
ok here I go
did you happen to see a weird shadow
monster cuz I sure did Oh like that a
lot less I like that a lot less oh boy
that is something straight out of my
nightmares
ok good good good great oh girl oh great
love that huh thanks you Oh
rust this is there's just a block of
rust that's not even a can or nothing
that's just a block the holy duty the
the holy duty divine sacrifice the
sacral rules of divine sacrifice oh
great I am gonna die I am going to die
ok alright can I pick up the spoon ok
can alright
great great great great so I've only got
one fuse I don't know if I'm supposed to
be able to I do not like you oh god damn
it damn ass you eat a bag of dicks
okay all right please please make your
diet predominantly dicks okay I'm gonna
put a fuse in this thing and you're
gonna not kill me talking about the
middle in here
yeah yeah right oh wait oh I see oh oh
whoa weird paper creature full of bugs
no no don't do nah
[Music]
no no I'm in the box you still there
buddy
you still there okay all right see ya
farewell farewell farewell geez okay
alright then good yeah Oh what is that
Oh what's what was that it's one of the
lost orchestra members set the game of
thrones opening good job good job bear
you're doing great Oh
[Music]
I got nothing to say about that you have
anything to say about that and for all I
know I just hallucinating that from all
the marsh blog that I inhaled it okay
all right where am I going now
where am I going now where'd my brother
leave me
okay still going I guess oh here we are
where are we now hi how's it going my
name is markiplier there anybody here
that maybe has seen one of my videos
yeah
it's alright come on in I'm a nice guy
why am I in a cage why did I voluntarily
put myself in a cage and who the hell
rigged up this system to pull this cage
across the marsh just conveniently
enough to drive by the corpse playing
the violin yeah okay can I get out now I
want to get off mr. bones wild ride
thank you for that okay oh what a lovely
Shack oh it's beautiful do you have any
books on human sacrifice in house hoping
and hoping the drowned spirit the
drowning goes trapped in the marsh
protects the territory around its body
those who come too close to it will be
possessed and destroy it in horrific
ways cuz why not okay all right all
right well I'm gonna die oh good a book
on sacrifice that's exactly what I was
looking for well down in the old dusty
trail and get into this Marsh yep
alright here we go I saw a path through
here did a grave stone or a rock rock
who built all this who did this why did
they do this why here
why'd they decide that here was the best
place for
all this I mean they must have known
that it was a marsh a bog even just full
of bad bro bro bro bro oh can I build a
brick it is can I build a bridge and I
built a bear
oh hello that was like an effigy can I
go in there no all right fine then so
what does this mean where do I go then
if I can't go that way then I gotta find
a way around I suppose whoa what the oh
oh that was not obvious that was a
hundred percent I had to go through a
gap in the rocks I mean I knew those
three planks of wood were illuminated
and I knew it had to be for a reason I
just didn't know I was supposed to go
through the gap okay alright carrying on
bro bro help Oh train tracks bro oh uh
who uh who would be coming through here
honestly
who do you think would be trudging their
way through this oh this looks bad I
mean it looks very similar to the rest
of the woods but I got a bad feeling
about it oh no I'm going into the MA
well that is a hell of an introduction
wouldn't you say that is a hell of a
hello did you happen to see an idiot
brother of mine holding a flashlight
that scared that okay looking back would
be a bad idea okay all right then okay
all right okay everything's fine
everything's fine I mean obviously
everything would be fine why wouldn't it
be fun camera's gonna fall right by me
in front of me I can't tell where no boy
is bad that's what I would call a whole
lot of bad no no no no please don't eat
me mr. troll please don't eat me please
I'm begging you please don't a mate is
that your stomach hers at you yeah no
rumbly in your mm glaze okay all right
bro bro tell the story about camp it'll
put him right to sleep
hey who knew this all this stuff this
Swedish lore was just waiting right
outside the city limits on the way to
the I rehabs hello hi okay
I don't know how I missed you but I dad
your big nice barn okay good bye good
catching up with you alright see ya dear
friend see brow
see ya dude alright anyway don't make my
way downtown walking fast trees past
jeez who the heck like why are these
even lit up anymore doesn't make any
sense
no no no
when is there stick in the middle of the
water
why is any of this anywhere Oh God round
house okay good okay all right okay all
right okay all right follow the power
line I think yes maybe yes want to give
that a whole lot of yes slide what no
moose to catch my fall find that Helberg
telephone okay all right good thing this
is ear I'm glad the infrastructures
reach this far out of town because
otherwise is that a water tower oh great
okay all right whoa oh okay well I seem
to have reached an impasse I'm gonna go
for the water tower I suppose
oh it's many oh this is creepy oh this
whole place I don't like it yeah all
right well I'm just gonna walk right
through not mine if they don't know why
these are air some kind of fever dream
I'm in all good a windmill oh I don't
know why all these ordinarily cheerful
things are just so creepy in this land
of all my ankles in this land of death
and dead oh good I couldn't see things
before now I can see them even less
where that window that's right there no
yes oh all right good that ain't good
none of that seems
what are you probably not good okay what
is going on in these woods
is this like some surreal experience
brought on by whatever the hell my
quote/unquote addiction is or is this
something more Oh bro
is that you something tells me that by
the loud grunting sounds it might be you
okay all right okay good great good good
good oh excuse me as a doc
ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay all right okay all right guys shut
up shut up shut up shut up who's there I
shut up
whoa where I shut up well I shut up shut
up shut up shut up shut up shut up shake
all right shut them up shut those
[ __ ] up it's just an endless woods
mixture of woods and marsh
Neverending where's my eye
I'm shutting up currently what happens
if I walk towards it bro cover me
Oh goodand I just can't
avert my eyes from that sweet hypnotic
ass I can't help it
what are you crunching on I got is about
[Music]
anyway that's all the time I got for
this episode but I am gonna finish this
game this is wonderful you know
ordinarily it was very much like a lot
of walking in this first episode but
somehow it kept it interesting the whole
time and I don't know how so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play this for yourself I will
provide a link to it in the description
below let me know what you thought down
in the comments and thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]